today i'm going to demonstrate a simple
way to attach a lay flat header pipe to
a regular garden hose
begin by using a clamp to attach a gray
barb connected to a leg flat header
if it is hard to get on use some food
grade lubricant like vegetable oil
tighten the clamp
wrap teflon tape around the threads on a
two inch male pvc coupling keeping in
mind the tape must go on clockwise so
that it doesn't bunch up when you screw
it into the grey bulb connector
use pipe wrenches to make sure it is
tight then apply pvc glue to the outside
of the three-quarter inch female reduced
threaded piece
and the inside of the two inch male pvc
cover
now we will wrap the threads of a 3 4
inch female connector with teflon tape
and screw it into the reducer
next apply more pvc glue which will
attach to a short two to three piece of
pvc three quarter inch pipe
apply more pvc glue to attach the valve
to the pvc
the valve has to flow in the right
direction so double check the direction
the arrow points use more pvc glue to
attach another short piece of pvc pipe
and then a three quarter inch female
connector then make sure the water hose
or faucet is clean and add teflon tape
to the threads
if you choose to add fertigation to the
irrigation system it should be attached
in the center of the pipe
we hope this video was very useful
please check out our video series to
learn all the steps in installing a
simple irrigation system on a small
phone thank you
you